good afternoon everyone
my name is daniela russ i'm a roboticist
and the director of mit's computer
science
and artificial intelligence laboratory
or csail as we know it
and also deputy dean of research in the
schwarzman college of computing
welcome to today's installment of hot
topics in computing
now our guest today needs no
introduction but i'd like to give him a
short one anyway
neil degrasse tyson is an astrophysicist
and arguably
the world's most well-known science
communicator
for nearly 25 years he directed the
hayden planetarium
at the american museum of natural
history while also writing
dozens of books and hosting beloved tv
shows and podcasts such as cosmos star
talk and nova
neil received his bachelor's degree in
physics from harvard and his phd in
astronomy
from columbia university and in addition
to
his uh degrees and his extraordinary
presence
in in the media neil received more than
a dozen
honorary doctorates as well as many
awards
and what i would like to highlight today
is the nasa distinguished published
service
medal which is the highest award given
by nasa
to non-government citizen
he's even got an asteroid named after
him
neil i'm so delighted that you made time
in your busy schedule to join us
today to continue the conversation we
started in december
to talk not just about the stars but
also
how astrophysics relates to the computer
science world
um so neil welcome back virtually
welcome to mit
yeah well thank you thanks for having me
back um i love your audience that's
always inquisitive and energetic and
with a
with a verve for learning and and
and asking questions and so i'm all in
i'm all in for all of that
so that's right i hope you're ready neil
because back in december
i had about 200 questions from our
amazing students left after our
conversation
and that number has doubled so let's get
started okay let's do it
that's just a question every 20 seconds
that's not a problem
now let me start with some questions
around the rise of data
and ai do you see potential in ai to
solve general questions about the
universe
or will ai be used to crunch numbers and
equations
yeah so i don't see ai getting ahead of
us
in our cosmic inquiries now maybe that's
just
because i don't want it to and
so so i accept that bias that i may have
i think i recognize that bias
but so much of the questions we ask
about the universe come about
by looking up and saying to ourselves
hmm that's odd that doesn't
match what it should what that's unusual
um isaac asimov made you know the great
author and
and science writer over many decades
uh he made the perceptive point that
true scientific discovery contrary to
what we think of with
was it um not aristotle archimedes
contrary to what the legend would have
you believe
true scientific discovery doesn't come
from somebody saying
eureka it comes from somebody saying
hmm that looks odd
right what's what's going on there
and so i guess ai if it's a complete
mapping of
all that it is to be human that i
suppose in principle
you could inculcate it with a sense of
curiosity
so that it will explore things it
doesn't know
and then bring to bear on it what it
does know to try to solve it
i don't see why that couldn't be the
case
but i don't know that we have good
examples of
ai yes we have ai's finding solutions to
problems that had eluded people
i knew that took place in chess and in
go um
even in something as simple as juggling
there were there were solutions to
these these these tasks that we've had
for so long
that the the computers found another
solution to it but would the computer
be able to invent another game for
example
right i'm still wondering whether ai can
get the
full sort of abject creativity
that we know humans are capable of
is ai gonna paint this behind me
is it going to come will it will it even
think
to paint something like that and
so i i don't know and i think cosmic
exploration
is so every year it's like who ordered
that what oh two black holes colliding
whether that oh let's try to measure
that okay oh the universe is expanding
oh the universe is accelerating
oh the universe had a beginning oh there
might be a multiverse i don't see ai
anywhere on that landscape so i know
it's your whole
bread and butter but i'm thinking it'll
be a long while if ever
before ai is sitting right next to me
scratching our head whatever the ai
scratches
to try to figure out a new question and
a new problem that sits in front of us
so from for me it's the data crunching
that happens
once we've already established the
problem and now we want to
calculate upon it so in an ideal world
if
if you could have anything out of an ai
or machine learning
uh system what would you like as an
astrophysicist
oh uh i was thinking what i want as a
person
let me answer that first uh yeah i'm
ready for
self-driving cars i'm ready for that you
know
i'm working on it are you okay well
hurry up okay
all right i got two kids who don't want
to drive one is like
20 and the other is 24 and i'm from the
city
so they don't want to drive and they're
like waiting for you
to send the the self-driving car okay so
um they're coming slowly what i like
especially about the self-driving car
is that it will know about all other
self-driving
cars in its vicinity so if it had to
change lanes it just tells them
i'm changing lanes and then they park
the the seas the the car changes lanes
and so
the the sources of so many accidents
would just evaporate overnight
and you'd have a safety factor that is
we're still losing 100 people a day to
car accidents
on the on on the freeways and highways
and pedestrians
in the united states so that would take
that near to near zero
if not identically zero in astrophysics
let me think i um hmm
i see a i
i i'm forgive me but i keep thinking of
ai as
a tool to help me do what i'm doing
rather than what i think a full up ai
should be capable of doing
which is completely replacing me all
right i send
the ai to my office okay and let it
handle all the phone calls and write the
book
and because if it's true a.i
then it should be just like me or better
especially better
all right and so i i don't know where to
where to put the dart
into the ai table to say this is where i
want it
versus this is where it will ever reach
so i don't that's probably a very
unsatisfying answer but i still
think of ai as just really good
computing
helping me solve the problems that i
posed and the questions that
that i am investigating
well neil that's uh that's an uh that's
a view that's consistent with many of
our views we're just trying to make the
tool more capable
and someday i hope we have a chance so i
could tell you about
um how long till those self-driving cars
do what you just said
but since we're talking about ai and
tools
what computing technology from today
would you have
the most trouble living without oh the
definitely the smartphone
i think the smartphone is the greatest
thing
ever conceived and invented in the
history of civilization
i don't think anything comes close to it
and it happened in our lifetime and and
and by the way
at any generation would say that about
whatever they might have invented right
let's go back 140 years or 30 years
the telegraph oh my gosh that's going to
change the world
oh we could you know and they lay down a
cable across the atlantic
you talk to europe when it used to take
you you know
however long to sail and so sure
when you're on an exponential growth
curve
if you are anywhere on that curve it
will feel like
all the greatest discoveries happen just
in the few recent years
but so it's not that you're living today
in a golden era the
entire era is a golden era because
everything is happening exponentially
and so
so so where do i come off then saying
the
smartphone is the greatest thing ever
just simply because of what technologies
it has merged
that it's extraordinary it takes better
photos than most people
ever took ever in the history of the
world it
more photos are being taken and this
this started out as a telephone
a freaking phone okay and i remember the
early
uh uh camera capacities there was it was
a fuzzy photo
and it was wasn't good and it was just
like for an emergency
now that's my camera of choice on my
telephone
oh wait it's not a telephone it's a it's
not only a telephone it's access to the
whole world's
information oh oh plus
where's where do i make the turn to get
to grandma's house and avoid the traffic
let me check the phone and it's getting
information from satellites
satellites that has precision timing
and the timing is so precise it has to
be corrected
for einstein's general theory of
relativity
because of the time dilation for it
being so
high up actually the opposite of time
dilation the
the the satellites are so far away from
earth's center and earth as a source of
gravity
that time ticks differently for it and
if it's giving you the time that you
think you need
it has to correct for that before it
hands it down so
this is a technology that is using like
relativity
space physics uh internet um
photography and i'm thinking what
what's left to do so
if i were to go back and bring one thing
to show isaac newton it would be
the smartphone well i'm excited you you
um really like the technology that was
produced by our field broadly
do you have any fears about it and in
particular
maybe connecting it to ai what is your
biggest
fear with respect to ai we know that
last year
you agreed with a fellow podcast guest
who said that the world's largest
existential crisis
is within a.i um what are you afraid of
and has your opinion changed since then
i don't think i if i agreed it might
have only just been a mild agreement
you know we've all seen the movies with
ai gone bad
and and often i don't know if i said
this when i was last
your guest but the science fiction
writer
ray bradbury is famously in response
to a question posed to him the question
was
um mr bradbury why do you write these
future stories um of such of science
gone bad
an apocalyptic earth is this the future
you think we're gonna have
and he said no i write these stories so
you
know what future to avoid
so so i don't mind the apocalyptic
movies they sell
tickets and they're they're always kind
of interesting
and maybe that'll help reset our
cautionary
um urges
uh to to say no i don't want that to
happen no that's pretty bad
oh that okay so and that's true of
course for
any technology i think there are other
more tangible existential threats than
ai
and that's why part ways with even ai
experts
who say this and feel this for me
the question is not will i ai take over
the world
that's for me that's not the right
question the right question is
when you have ai ability
what are you most likely going to do
with it
and i don't see anybody
maybe you're maybe in your in your
basement you got you're doing this
and you're not going to tell anybody but
personally
i don't and i've been on compute i've
been i
okay i'm not like total um
uh computer engineer but i've had my
my days on computer i probably coded 50
000 lines of computer code in my life
most of that in
in graduate school and shortly
thereafter that and in college
about 50 000 lines that's you know
that's respectable
but it's not as much as like real
professionals at it but i have i have
enough of a baptism
so i think that i have my thoughts have
some foundation
that's really what i'm trying to say
here so so
um when i think of computers and what
role they play
my first thought is not let's have the
computer
do everything that's just not my thought
my thought is let me get a computer that
makes a perfect cup of coffee
do i need that computer to guide my
self-driving car
no do i need my self-driving car to run
my laptop
no do i need so so
if you're gonna now say ai will be all
of this all wrapped up into one
humanoid bot who's gonna do that
i can't picture that as anybody's
priority
because anything you roll up into one
thing
i don't think is going to be good as
good as the
very specifically tasked
computing uh tool that
is applied to specific things in your
life
making it better and perhaps even
perfecting it
so i know general ai is supposed to be
able to do all of the above
okay is it going to walk my dog for me
is it going to is it gonna go to the
beach
for me people talk about oh we're gonna
upload our brains into computers and
then we're in the computer
uh i'm gonna take a stroll on a beach
and meet three people did the computer
do that
no no okay so it's not me anymore
all right me i continue living
a life of a flesh and blood human being
because i have two legs and i can walk
down the freaking beach
all right where's the computer in the on
the shelf you can think about it i
suppose
it can imagine meeting new people i
suppose
and maybe that's good enough and maybe
the difference doesn't matter like in
the movie the matrix if it's just all in
the head
who even knows and who even cares maybe
we're all in the matrix right now
but i just don't see the the all-purpose
computer taking over everything i just
don't see that
i agree um let me move on to the next
question
um oh can i add one thing sorry again i
don't remember if i said this last time
i'm old enough to remember the jetsons
this is a hannah barbaric cartoon that
like co-existed in time with the
flintstones
it's interesting to have the stone age
and the future
all as like prime time cartoons half
hour cartoons
that were part of the canon of what i
grew up with
and in there of course he's in a flying
car of course
it's the future and he's living up in
the clouds of course
all right so what do you have well
they have a robot made
and it looks like a it's wearing like a
maid
thing okay and so the
maid is like
pushing the buttons to clean the laundry
and to do the things and i'm thinking
no the you don't need the maid to push
the button let the laundry machine be
the computer
you don't need a robot to get in your
car to drive your car
your car is the robot so all of these
movies that show
humanoid robots who's going to do that
no i've seen some attempts at it i don't
i don't see any
people lined up to get a human robot
walking around their house and if the
demand isn't there the supply's not
going to be there i don't
so i don't see it sorry in fact
with uh it's it's interesting to think
about the robotic technologies over the
past 50 years
um many robots were actually inspired by
the human form
with arms and humanoid shapes but we can
roboticize
everything in the any in the built
environment we can create
so many uh more shapes and that's where
the the robotics
future is that very important and let me
echo that because
the idea that you would create a robot
that's humanoid
comes with the implication that the
human form is some ideal
thing no no i mean it wouldn't be great
if you had eight arms like an
octopus all right that would be like
really you could be really effective
i mean just be a little more creative
about that right
to create another human i don't need
that i got enough humans i don't need
you to make a robot human
no yeah so you tune the robot for the
task
physically kinetically
so that that task is perfected by the
morphological form of that robot and you
know something when you've done that
that robot is not the robot making your
morning coffee or your laundry
and it's not the one driving your car so
we have a number of students working on
exactly those problems
but let me move on and ask you about uh
more astrophysics harvard's avilobe
argues that was an interstellar alien
probe what do you think
he was able to get very few people to
agree with that conclusion
among his colleagues so we can talk
about this
outlying idea and
part of what made it get so much
attention
is his academic affiliation with harvard
you
barely ever saw his name without harvard
chair of the harvard department so
harvard was
he would ride in that sort of harvard
affiliation in the recognition he was
getting for those ideas
um very few people uh aligned
with that but apart from
and by the way in science if you have a
really you can have
crazy ideas that turn out to be true but
generally
the effort to establish that truth is
you go through peer review and you say
no you forgot this so no you forgot to
cross the t
dot the i carry the two and if you can't
get colleagues to embrace what you just
came up with
then then you know maybe you should
rethink what you're doing
okay that's the whole point of peer
review but so anyhow
um uh the his paper by the way that
uh suggested omumua being that just
just make sure we're all on the same
page we disagree the
astrophysics community discovered our
very first we've been looking for
these for decades our very first
interstellar
visitor coming through the solar system
and it's you can determine that
instantaneously by
establishing its orbital parameters not
instantaneously you get a few
positions of its orbit and you know is
it is it on a hyperbolic orbit or is it
on an elliptical orbit if it's
hyperbolic
it does not belong to this solar system
this we knew
from jump street it did not belong in
the solar system it got a lot of
attention because of this
then we noticed we the people who who
you know the the asteroid solar system
folk
noticed that it had an what's called an
anomalous acceleration
you add up the gravity of all the
planets and the sun
and everything else you know about and
it's moving a little extra
than what the gravity that should be
influencing it
could account for and so
by the way that's not so weird in the
solar system
comets exhibit this all the time why as
they near the sun
heat from the sun um sublimates
the ices and you can get ice jets um
gaseous jets um creating
thrust on what's otherwise a nicely
newtonian path thereby disrupting
what you might otherwise think is is the
perfect laws of gravity
all right the problem with omumua is
nobody saw any jets coming out of it
there was none of this
telltale cometary fuzz
and so that meant it was a conundrum so
people for a while said
we don't know what's causing this avi
lope jumped right in and said
aliens and i'm that's just not my
first guess at something if i don't know
what it is
all right i'm gonna work i'm gonna
really
i'm i will scratch my head more
before that's the conclusion i land on
because if
everything you don't understand you want
to
credit aliens i i what kind i don't know
what what is that and it turns out some
geologists figured out
uh it's it's probably outgassing of a
kind we're not familiar with
on solar system style comets it is after
all
from another place okay so
it easily accounts for it and but um
avi had a sort of day in the sun where
everybody wanted to hear
how it is that aliens are visiting our
solar system
by the way you know happy all or physics
this is mit right see all of physics
fluent so so
the anomalous acceleration was a single
extra x uh force operating on it
that altered its path from what would
otherwise be a pure newtonian um
a trajectory okay
um i'm thinking if it's aliens
they would zigzag through the solar
system they're not they're not going to
still be
on a smooth path if they got if they
have controlled acceleration
my gosh nothing's stopping it and if it
did a planetary tour and hung out
checked out the earth then i say you
know avi let's revisit that suggestion
that maybe aliens are in control so
so that's that's what you have there oh
by the way
the monitoring of the sky
for things that go bump in the night
is the sole task of a very new telescope
which was previously known as the large
synoptic
survey telescope lsst
it got renamed thankfully to the vera
rubin telescope
one of the more famous members of our
community uh
who discovered dark matter in galaxies
uh she died a few years ago vera rubin
so it's called the vera rubin telescope
this telescope and it
dovetails back to your whole existence
here this telescope
i forgive me i'm not fluent in the
numbers i'd have to look them up and
they're very look-up-able
but it's basically going to take a
snapshot
of the entire sky
multiple times a night thereby making
a movie of the night sky
now you say to yourself why do you need
a movie if nothing changes
well how do you know nothing changes
you've never had a movie of it
okay so so um and there are other things
where you can if you only observe
something
at the same time each night suppose
something blinks on
once every 24 hours you'll think the
thing is
constantly in the same state because you
don't have data from the rest of the
phasing
of what that thing is is doing this
telescope is going to solve that
and it is the largest data project there
ever was
in my field and it is almost entirely
uh computing there's the the
there's the pipeline of data that gets
um analyzed
and there's a serendipity mode where it
gets automatically analyzed
and compares it with an image the night
before or earlier in that night
and if anything is different it goes
back to it and signals
other people to possibly turn other
telescopes onto that zone
so this is modern astrophysics that
would be
impossible without very clever
programming
of the management and analysis of data
where should the vera rubin telescope
look for life
yes well if if it's coming in on a
flying saucer it'll
find it but if you're going to look for
life chemically or in other ways
you want to send a probe maybe to the
planetary surface as we've done with
mars
the perseverance rover that's that's we
it's called a rover but it's really a
mobile bio laboratory it's also got some
geophysics tools in it as well
we don't have a word for mars geology
because geo means earth
so so with mars geology it's kind of a
misnomer but uh anyhow it's it's doing
these experiments in an attempt to
establish
and understand and characterize the
environment on mars so that we can
pose the next round of questions was
there ever life there
is there life there now if it's there
now is it underground and how far
underground and if there's water there
is the water liquid is there a heat
source
that we haven't reckoned before all of
these questions get asked in the search
for life
but i can tell you that if a flying
saucer comes through our airspace
um the veriruben telescope is going to
catch it early
speaking of uh of looking for life on
mars
do you expect to see life in the seas of
titan uh in our solar system
uh so titan so let's uh so just to again
to catch people up
uh titan is one of the moons of saturn
and in fact it's the it's one of the
biggest moons in the whole solar system
uh actually and it's
it has an atmosphere oh my god a moon
with an atmosphere well if you have an
atmosphere that means you can establish
sort of partial pressures on things that
might then be sustained as liquid
all right once you lose your atmosphere
liquids are not stable right and they
just evaporate
or um in out so if
titan has an atmosphere let's look for
liquids and
what's the atmosphere made of well it's
mostly methane
all right ch3 so you got methane but
titan is way out there
all right jupiter is far enough now you
double that
and you get to saturn and moon around
saturn it's way outside
you know the goldilocks zone okay all
right so
we're not gonna expect liquid water no i
don't think so
so you get there and there are these
boulders because we've landed on the
surface of
your european probe attached to an
american
orbiter around saturn uh huygens probe
named after christian huygens a polymath
a dutch polymath from the era
from the 1600s so he
and 1700s so he um
the huygens probe deployed and descended
onto the surface of titan
through the atmosphere it was able to
make a soft landing because there's an
atmosphere you could just use a
parachute when we landed on the moon you
couldn't use a parachute
you needed to spend fuel to prevent
yourself from crashing
this is part of the fuel budget that you
have to consider depending on where you
want to go
in the solar system so here's titan but
then you ask what's the temperature of
titan
and i forgot what it is but it's cold
enough to liquefy
methane oh my gosh
well if you can liquefy methane and
there's partial pressures to keep it
liquid
we should look for lakes
oh my gosh they found lakes methane
lakes
on titan okay they were closer to the
poles than we had thought maybe there'd
be more towards the equator
so all right well where's the water
because
really water is not uncommon in the
universe oh
the water's frozen into bedrock
so here on earth when we see rocks
we say rocks are solid no rocks are
solid at room temperature
go inside a volcano rocks are liquid
okay
so what is water on titan it is frozen
solid it is the bedrock and those are
the mountains that
those are water and the liquid
is liquid methane so let's ask the
question
what does it take to have life are we
going to invoke a water bias and say
uh life as we know it's got to have
liquid water so let's look for liquid
water
maybe all life really needs
is liquid and
maybe methane liquid methane
is a whole is a foundation for a whole
other kind of life form
that our imagination prevents us
from conjuring because we are so
earth biased in our biology
so i like the question could there be
life on titan because if there
is it will completely stretch
our understanding of all the ways of
being alive
what chemistry do you expect non-dna
life form to use so here's an
interesting let me
sort of not answer that question with
another comment
um if you speak to geologists and they
look at mars
they see rocks and they say oh there's
you know there are iron oxides and
there's silicates and
they can use the same vocabulary
that they use on earth when they're
talking about the rocks on mars
so what it means is minerals
geology as a general field
is highly portable in your understanding
of processes
from one rocky planet to another
well if that's let's call that a
universal thing that minerals
do under certain temperatures and
pressures
should we not presume that the way
life formed on earth wouldn't be exactly
the way
life would form anywhere else
should we require that identity gets
encoded
in ways that do not invoke dna
when geologists are not saying oh here's
a here's a here's an
element we've never no we've got the
elements we've got the periodic table
planets are not inventing new elements
that we haven't already discovered
we've got that okay so could it be
that biological processes are as
repeatable
as the formation of rocks that's an
interesting question and if it's the if
that's the case
then we could declare that the dna
molecule is an inevitable consequence
of complex chemistry and no longer have
to
ask ourselves what would life be like
without dna
so that's my that's a way to not answer
your question but with another sort of
probing thought about this
and by the way life on earth formed
really fast we've been around four and a
half billion years
the first half a billion it was the
conditions on earth's surface were very
hot
uh we were still accreting material from
the solar system
so that would break apart complex
molecules
just the the binding energy is less than
the
impact energy of rocks so then finally
we cool down
now we can make complex chemistry
once the start the clock at that point
it took 100 million years
for life to show up yeah that sounds
like a long time
but what's 100 million years compared
with 4 billion
so left to itself earth made life
and so how why should i think and just
because we have a hard time making life
in the lab
we haven't figured it out yet we got top
people on it though just
we haven't figured it out doesn't mean
nature didn't figure it out or that
nature won't figure it out
wherever it has access to complex
chemistry and as your audience surely
knows
all the ingredients of life the hydrogen
the oxygen the silicon the carbon
all of that are the most common
ingredients across the universe
so if we were made of like a isotope of
bismuth you'd have you could say yeah
life is rare
life as we know yeah we're special but
no
no the three of the the top three
chemically active ingredients in the
universe in order
are the order in which you find them in
life on earth
excuse me so the top four is that
hydrogen is the number one
element in life okay the num the number
two element in the universe is helium
but it's chemically inert
it doesn't count what's next carbon
oxygen
these next two elements are that are two
and three
in the universe the oxygen is more
abundant than carbon
and that's what we're made of so life
was
really opportunistic with its
ingredients and plus you got carbon in
the middle of it
which is extraordinarily sticky
chemically sticky
and it combined to itself with its four
electrons and it can buy
with another four it'll get two two and
two you get one one one one and one
and one one one and one and it can make
long chains just like what the
um double helix is so anyhow i'm i'm
going to vote for the double helix
at least for now that's great
um okay more about our universe
um is our universe expanding within a
different universe
i'm sorry are we expanding is our
universe
expanding within a different universe oh
yes so let me um
shape that up a bit here so uh we have
modern understanding of the application
of quantum physics
to the early universe the big bang
basically
um it allows us if you only use sort of
einsteinian physics
for the big bang it's kind of limiting
all right but when the whole unit
because quantum physics is the physics
of the small
and general relativity is the physics of
the large but at the big bang
the large was small so if the large is
small and rivals the sizes of particles
then you get to apply quantum rules
that impact the entire universe that's a
fun
place to hang out it's kind of also a
shotgun wedding there because
the two don't really play well in the
sandbox
all right uh you need like a third
understanding of how this
works and this is where string theorists
come in and other sort of high-level
cosmologists but when you follow
some natural consequences of this
marriage
uh one other thing and with a um
an inflationary scenario uh inflation
um alan guth mit professor one of the
pioneers of that concept
when you when you invoke this you you
learn that this this thing
can make multiple universes multiple
expanding bubbles
and so if that's the case
then we are one expanding bubble
inside of a larger
universe that has other expanding
bubbles within it
now you could be an expanding bubble in
an expanding universe
where everybody is expanding and you'll
never actually bump into one another
if the universe is expanding faster than
your bubble is for example
okay so then you'll never catch up and
that's an interesting scenario you can
rank
these multi-verses by their simplicity
or their
complexity and that one would be the
simplest example of one
because these other universes still
share in a way they share our space time
they would have the same laws of physics
they might have a different amount of
matter in them or whatever
and and you know but and there could be
an infinite number of them
in this book that just came out a month
ago can i show it is that crash
cosmic queries i've got to show it there
uh cosmic queries this is these are
this is a book that's collected the
deepest questions we've ever asked
about the universe in the history of our
civilization
so in here is like how did it all begin
how did it get to be this way what is it
all made of
how will it all end and there's a whole
section here on
what does nothing have to do with
everything because how do you define
nothing is it where there's no matter
well suppose there's energy okay let's
take away the energy is it no quantum
phenomena let's take that away
well there's still the fabric of space
and time getting curved by gravity
although let's take that away well then
there's still the laws of physics that
apply let's take that away
so what does it mean then to have a
region of space where you don't even
have laws of physics that apply
we go there in this book because there's
a category of questions
that are just dangling by our ankles off
the cliff
right and we're dangling there because
we don't
let's just is the question even the
right question that we're asking
so um so that's one category of universe
a whole other category of universe
is allows the different multiverses to
have
different laws of physics within them
and so
and they get more and more spooky and
scary
actually for me because i lose sleep
over some of these um and so that's
it's a fun exercise in pushing the
limits of your physics and your math
to see what fate awaits us and for me
the scariest fate is the possibility
that the
accelerated expansion of the universe
this is that
dark energy you may have read about
if that goes unchecked then
that stretching of the fabric of space
and time
will overcome the
elasticity of space-time itself
and when that happens it will rip
at the pixelated level of what the
universe
of what constructs the universe and
that's the planck length
this planck length all right that that
is the quantization of the universe that
general relativity
doesn't see that's why you needed a
third theory to put them together but
that pixelization of the universe
as you expand there's a point where it
wants to expand that
how do you expand the basic building
print the basic building
pixel of the universe you can't so it's
called the big rip
and if it goes unchecked that'll happen
in about 20 billion years
so that's what i really lose sleep on we
want to talk about other universes
time to move to another universe then
well
speaking of our own universe how will
our galaxy still collide with andromeda
despite this expansion good it'll
collide before that becomes a problem
okay yeah so so as we continue to expand
the strength of the dark energy
gains relative to the strength of
gravity
and right now we can still have solar
systems and and
and galaxies uh and and nearby galaxies
falling towards one another
you go a little too far away the
expansion of the universe is
overriding the urge of the galaxies to
come together and that's where we get
our
whole understanding of the expanding
universe but nearby galaxies
our strength of gravity is strong enough
so that the expanding universe
is not overtaking this just yet and we
will collide with andromeda
any six seven billion years from now and
we even have a word for that new galaxy
i thought it was very creative
it's called the uh milk comeda
or milka media but you know there's
andromeda and the milky way
milk comeda i think was it's a little
clumsy but it's cute
how close are we to finding a unified
equation that explains all matter
so i have a lot of thoughts about that
not that i have any
actual talent to participate in that
exercise
okay but i think a lot about it and i
just wonder
um that very question contains
a very deep bias that the universe
actually can be described by a simple
equation
what a that's an interesting
philosophical bias
you're imparting your own sense of order
and elegance
onto a very complex universe and i try
to stay open-minded
maybe the universe is just messy all
right
maybe the all forces don't come together
as one
may maybe i'm gonna allow for that
you know why because i studied johannes
kepler a mathematician german
mathematician
around this time of galileo and
shakespeare and queen
elizabeth a very fertile time in europe
around the year 1600. he was sure
because he was a mathematician and he
knew about the platonic solids
you know about this if you know anything
about any geometry you know there's only
five
platonic solids so these are solid
shapes where every surface
is an identical polygon okay an
identical
uh uniform polygon so a triangle so what
do you have you can have
four triangles will make a pyramid
that's one of the five
uh platonic solids another one is a cube
each side is a square you keep doing
this there are five of them it turns and
no more and no fewer all right
so he's a he loved math and he knew the
universe must be perfect god made it
god's perfect math is perfect
so clearly the movement of the planets
around the sun must have and there's six
known planets mercury venus
earth mars jupiter and saturn and he has
five
of these solids so he decided to nest
the solids
all right and then put orbits in the
gaps between them because if you have
five solids you have six gaps or there's
an outer
zone as well and if you do that he's
saying yeah that's gotta be it
because that is beautiful because it is
simple because that's how
it must be and he spent 10 years
working on this and he said no
it's not that it's and they're not
perfect circles
no they're ellipses and they're
different shape ellipses
at that and so the the whole
perfect um philosophy of what was
guiding his inquiry
had to be thrown out the window so
maybe there's a unified field theory
that captures
all the forces of nature simplifying
everything in the universe into one
equation maybe
but my read of history tells me every
time we layer our own
requirements on what nature ought to be
we end up with egg in our face so i'm
not
i'm not betting on it should we put more
effort into colonizing mars
uh i would ask why would you want to
colonize mars
what's your goal i'm asking you right
now
uh well uh the idea of colonizing mars
could uh could help us uh from uh
escaping
our climate armageddon for instance okay
good good all right
so that's a common thought and it makes
a good headline too and elon musk
and and carl sagan and
um and uh stephen hawking
you know some very visible thinkers in
recent decades
have made very strong suggestions that
we should become at least a two planet
species
to ensure our survival in case there's
some kind of
catastrophe or armageddon uh rendering
us extinct on one of the planets
that makes a good headline but i'm i'm
i'm a little more practical than that
so i have a i'm swimming upstream in the
ideas i'm about to share with you
they're not ideas they're just they're
just
i'm just my sensibility is different
from that of others and here's why
all right uh if you want to colonize
mars now well
you can't because you can't breathe the
air so you have to build some kind of
habitat module
all right so if you build a habitat
module
and then you go to mars well you're not
really living on mars you're living
on earth on mars because you just
created a habitat
well that's like going to disneyland all
right i don't mind visiting mars and
going to disneyland
spending a few weeks all right and then
coming back
sure but you want to colonize mars and
have people live there
permanently on a planet where you can't
breathe
the air people say well we had just
explorers from the
15th century who went out not knowing
where they'll land sure
columbus visits the new world all right
he gets off his ship he can breathe the
air
other human beings are there to greet
him
he can eat the fruit growing on the
trees and
the trees are made of wood just like the
trees in europe
if his ship breaks he can mend his ship
if you crash land on mars you can't go
to the home depot
and get a new to get pliers or you can't
get anything
let alone not being able to breathe the
air so
in order to really become a two planet
species we have to terraform
mars terraforming i love me some
terraforming don't get me i love it
okay great idea so you seed it with
microbes and certain chemistries
that then uh operate on their own
um uh on their own uh chemical by their
own chemical
forces to generate oxygen and all this
okay
so now we figure out how to terraform
mars it's
it's a stretch but it's not out of reach
it's not out of our imagination
terraform mars
now we ship a billion people there now
we have our eggs in two baskets instead
of one
all right and now here's my issue are
you worried about it a killer asteroid
it seems to me that whatever effort
it took to terraform mars
and ship a billion people there is
greater than whatever effort it would
take to deflect the asteroid
i'm just thinking an asteroid's coming
let's deflect it
no first let's terraform mars and ship a
billion people there
and then everyone here dies so that
they've survived no let's
deflect the asteroid all right what else
uh there's a killer virus that goes
around
and all right what investments will be
required
in virology to create a perfect
antiviral serum
is that in reach i don't know i'm
guessing it's less money
less time and less energy to terraform
mars and ship a billion people there
and finally here we are we're trashing
this planet
climate change makes it unlivable oh my
gosh
what do we do okay so we
terraform mars and ship a billion people
there but wait a minute
um if we have the power of
geoengineering
to turn mars into earth
then we have the power of geo
engineering to turn earth back into
earth
so so all of these arguments i don't
see them having practical meaning
as a solution i i just now i i want to
be a two planet species but the
motivation shouldn't be
so that half of us can go there so that
one of these planets could go extinct
no no save everybody
let's see is that so wrong
let's just be a two planet species
because that's fun to do because that
i'd
that'd be great all right i'd that's
that would be my reason for doing it
not as as the as the imagined excuse to
save
the species well yeah speaking of
climate armageddon uh
what do you think we need to do to save
the planet yeah so it's
uh armageddon when i think of armageddon
i think of something more catastrophic
than what climate change will bring
to us okay so we are putting
carbon that has been long buried uh
long buried in the ground uh with
turning that into carbon dioxide
right as the product of burning fossil
fuels
and all right so we are warming the
earth
this will have catastrophic consequences
to coastlines
as we melt the land-based
all right and all that water sort of
flows into the oceans and the ocean
levels rise i live in new york city
you can do the calculation if greenland
loses its ice and antarctica loses its
ice
the water level will rise to the
left elbow of the statue of liberty
so basically all of new york city is
under water and so is basically every
other major city
we've ever built in the history of
civilization because cities were built
where there was commerce where there was
transportation where there was and
where's that that's on the water's edge
so if all of what founded civilization
is put in threat because of these rising
uh tidewaters then yeah that's
a really bad future for us but we will
survive it as a species
there's not uh it's it's not an
armageddon it's like a it's a
it's a slow burn actually it's a fast
burn and we're not going to be able to
respond
nimbly enough to it you have to pick up
every coastal city and move it inland
100 miles
all right or 50 miles uh can we do that
over decades no
because these cities took centuries
to to build and to perfect and to and to
develop and to
to to to have them function
in the ways that civilization needs and
requires
so so now the reason why i say this
there was a day before we had fossil
fuels
we earth all right all right there was
it's called the the carboniferous era
of earth all that carbon was plant life
okay and so and earth was hot we didn't
have polar ice caps
life was doing just fine but it
humans had not yet come along and humans
had not yet built cities
dependent on what we presumed would be a
stable climate
so so earth will definitely survive
anything we do to it
but our civilization as we've come to to
define it will not
we can call that armageddon but uh
there'll be still
people who will survive but it'll be a
really ugly
world at that point uh
neil we are coming up to the top of the
hour so let me ask you
one uh one last question well i have two
questions i'll answer ease in half the
time
how about that last two questions okay
um
so um what um
what do you see as as a landing on the
moon moment for today's time something
that transcends national interests
uh something that can unify the world
you know could unify the world
um a virus
that can attack any and all humans
and would be a pandemic and we all have
to band together to fight it
oh that already happened and we didn't
band together oh
silly me uh generally
people band together when they have a
common need and a common urge
and the covet virus was a
was a practice run for invading aliens
an invading alien wants to kill all
humans it's time to get together folks
uh pool our resources put it put aside
your tribal ways
in fact let's collect your tribalism
into one
sense of the world and that one sense of
the world is that
you know what race are you we are all
the human race
all right now let's fight this common
enemy we failed that the only
the only success story was the the
medical researchers
who developed the virus and the the the
antiviral
uh vaccine in record time that's the
that that's why i wouldn't give it quite
an f
of a covered year i'd give it like a c
plus and all that
the fact that it's not an f is because
we got the the vaccine going
even though the distribution had
problems so
um you know why should we need
a sputnik moment or a moon moment why
we know we all enjoyed it we know it
transformed our culture our civilization
our technologies it stoked our economies
we know this why do we have to feel
threatened again
just to engage in exploration on the
frontier
knowing from past experience that such
exploration
can be transformative to how we live
so uh yeah that's my answer to that
question
thank you for that uh okay last question
yeah you could go back to your
21 year old self which is the age of
many of the students who are with us
today
what advice would you give
all right i i haven't i have what might
be an unsatisfying
answer for you okay
um everything i
am today everything down to the
tiniest detail
is what it is because
of throughout your life you you test
things you experiment things and you
learn you learn to do things better or
this didn't work and you learned this
if someone goes back in time and says
don't do that that's not going to work
and they just
tell you then that's not part of your
life experience
that's just somebody handing you their
life experience
so when i think of advice
the advice is keep exploring just keep
doing what you're doing
and yeah there'll be some failures in
there you'll learn from those there'll
be some
some successes you'll do more of that
but you will have experienced that on
your own as the consequence of your own
creativity and so
uh it reminds me of it's now if it's an
apocryphal story
but let me just tell such a story so
you have an immigrant who comes to the
united states with twenty dollars in
their pocket
right and then they work hard and they
struggle and they take
odd jobs and then they and then they
finally
uh own a business all right because they
worked hard and they worked their way up
and they had more they saved
they own a business they get married
they have children
and then they have multiple businesses
and they become really successful
and it lives in a whole mansion but that
person struggled
his entire life trying to make ends meet
barely getting food on the plate okay so
now
they're well off and they have kids and
they make sure
that the kids do not struggle
the way they did they make sure the kids
always have food on their plate
the way they did because i don't want my
kids to struggle the way i did
and then the kids grow up and they're 21
years old
and they're deadbeats and then the
parents say
where did we go wrong we gave you
everything we didn't have
that's where you went wrong because you
became
what you were because of the challenges
and struggles that you faced in your
life
i don't i think we undervalue
struggle in what role it can play
in your future success in your future
perspectives
your outlooks your your sense of the
world
especially since almost hardly anything
worth achieving will you end up
achieving without a struggle
and if someone says here just do that
then you don't have to struggle well
okay you made your life
easier but is that really
what you just want an easy life really
okay go ahead and get it could take your
easy life
what's gonna happen when there's some
stress in your life oh you'll freak out
all right
you won't know how to handle it you'll
you'll
so i don't know i don't want to play
psychologist here
but they're people who are having
trouble in school because they're not
socialized in the right way and they're
getting bullied so they take them out of
the school
they put them in a different school
where everyone is nice to each other and
then when they go
get older and they get into the
workplace and then there's the difficult
person
in the other cubicle they don't know how
to handle them okay
i keep thinking so much of what also
goes on in school
beyond the classwork is the
learning how to deal with difficult
people
and so yeah so in terms of advice no i
wouldn't
i don't know that i have advice but
suppose i said
yeah be spend less time doing athletics
and more time
because i was i did a lot of athletic
and more time in your studies
yeah i maybe i i could have done that
but then i wouldn't have this
appreciation for sports that i currently
do and i wouldn't have the
conversations that i have with sports
enthusiasts and i'm actually like
friends
with well strong acquaintances with the
coach
of of the seattle seahawks that's just
fun
okay and i have a fluency in sports that
has enriched my life in ways
that wouldn't have been there if i gave
up all my sports at the time and then i
only had my head in the books
i used to do i didn't doodle in class i
don't have any art ability but i would
play with my pen as though i were a
calligrapher and i would do
um fancy lettering and it turns out that
the new york times the banner head
it's in gothic a lot of the letters in
the new york times appear in my name
so i pull out those letters and i do
them and there i am like
and why i really should have been paying
attention in class and why does this
accrue at all
well i now have a collection of fountain
pens and i dip them in
in inky and ink ink bottles and when i
sign my books
okay i sign them with calligraphy pen
and people like
they like that all right i do that and
it gets it gets on their doorstep and it
shows up on social media
a little thing like that that's enriched
my life it's enrich the lives of others
so don't tell me future person
what i should or shouldn't be doing i'm
i'm perfectly happy to experiment and
learn from it on my own
thank you for that neil thank you for
being with us thank you for
inspiring us and um encouraging us
i look forward to the next time you and
i have a chance to meet
in the meantime we'll work really hard
on those self-driving cars
in fact i want to get you on my podcast
star talk
uh what the day the first self-driving
car fully self-driving drives off the
lot
i want you in my studio to interview you
oh one thing about your
your here's the advice to give my 21
year old self you ready
um make sure you actually do learn from
your mistakes
that's the advice all right you don't
want to ever make the same mistake twice
wasting your life and time and everybody
else's
awesome advice thank you neil hi
danielle always good to see you and i
love you've got the
horsehead nebula behind you a little bit
of my our universe there there's the
horse's head you're blocking
you're blocking the thing that gives it
its name i just want you to to know that
that was a test for you okay no i know i
know my sky ah you know
don't do you think you're talking to
here
it was uh was taken in my backyard oh it
was excellent
excellent what was this this was taken
in my backyard
well thank you all for joining us thank
you neil okay and everybody in mit land
uh stay strong stay smart
and um you know you all know
that you're you're going to become the
engines of tomorrow's economies and
tomorrow's
science literacy just keep it going
absolutely